في الخنادق، كلما قمت بالحفر بشكل أعمق، كانت
الخطوط الأمامية أفضل في
السهول المفتوحة في شرق أوكرانيا وهي عبارة عن خطوط متعرجة
من الأعمال الترابية في هذه المنطقة،
ظلت المواقع ثابتة لفترة من الوقت، وكان
أليكسي من لواء الدبابات الأول
هنا لمدة ستة أشهر،
وكان الجو هادئًا في بعض الأحيان.  يقول وأحيانًا يكون الصوت
مرتفعًا أحيانًا
يحاول الروس الاختراق
حتى الآن ولم ينجحوا حسنًا،
قد ترغب في النزول حسنًا،
قيل لنا
أن الخطوط الروسية على بعد كيلومتر واحد فقط
من هنا، ونسمع
قصفًا عرضيًا
ولكن لا شيء قادم  في هذا المنصب،
ومع ذلك، قام
هذا الجندي أيضًا بتسمية أقرانه
من خلال منظار عبر المنطقة الحرام
ولكن لفترة وجيزة فقط لتجنب إطلاق نيران القناصة
لأكون صادقًا في البداية، كنت خائفًا، كما
يقول، ولكن يمكن للبشر أن يعتادوا على
كل شيء لم
يعتادوا عليه بعد  التهديد
يحوم فوق رؤوسنا
حسنًا، لقد اتخذنا الآن غطاءً لأن
الجنود يقولون إن هناك طائرة بدون طيار تحلق
فوق المنطقة، وأخبرونا
أحيانًا بإسقاط قنابل يدوية على خنادقهم
ولكن ليس هذه المرة
في المؤخرة، حيث يتحقق الرقيب أوليغ من أن
ضباطه من الحقبة السوفيتية-  64 دبابة في
حالة عمل جيدة،
إنها مثل سيارة قديمة يسهل إصلاحها أو ما
شابه ذلك، يخبرني أنه مع السيارات الجديدة عليك أن
تأخذها إلى الميكانيكي، فهي تشبه
جرارًا بسيطًا
ولكن هذه الجرارات قد يتم استبدالها قريبًا
بموديلات أحدث، كما يقول بعضًا منها
رفاقه في بولندا يتدربون على
استخدام دبابات النمر الألمانية الصنع، وقد
وصل الربيع إلى هذه الأجزاء
ومعه ترقب متزايد
لهجوم أوكراني، يمكن لأسلحة جديدة أكثر حداثة
من هذه الدبابات القديمة أن تحدث
فرقًا كبيرًا
في الخنادق، كل شيء هادئ ولكن  بينما
نترك طائرة بدون طيار تظهر فوقنا،
تصل رحلتنا بعد
30 ثانية، حسنًا
في المدفعية، لا يوجد وقت نضيعه
ولكننا كنا سنصبح شرق أوكرانيا